[Music]  pregnant Khloe Kardashian is slang in  sheer lingerie for a new photo shoot  check out the 33 year old mom to be  smouldering for her new good American  campaign Khloe has that pregnancy glow  as she rocks a super sexy see-through  bra and super high ponytail styled by  hair stylist and roof it's Simon Coco's  makeup artist H rush posted another  behind-the-scenes shot of the reality  star bearing her bump captioned slang at  seven months it's just all like weird  what's happening I think it's just like  you're growing a human Khloe is still  keeping busy as an entrepreneur before  welcoming her first child with Tristan  Thompson last month she shared a sneak  peak on snapchat of her latest denim  line with expected mothers in mind  wearing jeans during their pregnancy I  think you look so cute and chic and  there's only so many dresses or leggings  they can wear every day  [Music]